Oh
that AIDS and HIV is a very unpleasant
thing and just because people aren't
dying as frequently as they used to that
doesn't mean that it would really suck
if you had it I think it's really
disheartening how complacent a lot of
younger gay men specifically have gotten
when it comes to safe sex and HIV and
seeing you know the numbers increase it
sucks
I mean I'm fortunate that I'm you know
I'm not young enough not super old
either but I was around when people were
still dying and safe sex was such an
important message you know I remember
when Pedro Zamora died and I was so
heartbroken when I was growing up Pedro
Zamora was the only gay person I saw
representing me in the media I could
relate to him on so many levels I was
gay he was gay I'm CUBAN he was Cuban
and he was just being himself and being
on TV and so inspiring I wish that I
could have had someone like me to when I
was younger you know I I would like to
think that despite the fact that I'm
controversial or maybe even because of
it that I inspire young gay people
because they can say hey look at that
dude he may be annoying or really
opinionated and I may not agree with
everything he says but I love the fact
that he's able to be himself and be
successful because that hopefully tells
that young gay kids that you can be
yourself and be successful you don't
have to change who you are or try to fit
yourself into whatever mold you're told
that you have to fit in you know you can
be who you are and accomplish your
dreams or even better than what you have
ever had ever dreamt of
all minority groups function differently
from other minority groups
that's just how everybody operates you
know being Cuban is just another part of
who I am and I'm very involved in that
community as well you know recently I
helped with my time and drawing a lot of
attention to this protest in Los Angeles
for human rights abuses in Cuba and
recently also I've been drawing a lot of
attention to the situation in Arizona
and you know I'm just doing my part and
I'm happy to do my part
well in Arizona they recently passed a
law requiring all immigrants or people
that look like they're in the country
illegally
to have documentation and that is a very
scary thing because it's going to lead
to racial profiling and you know it's
like stopping people on the street
because they look gay and if you're gay
you gonna get sent back to the gay part
of town
being gay in the Cuban community for me
was not the easiest experience that's
one of the reasons why I left Miami and
went to New York City to go to college
because I didn't feel like I could be
myself and stay living in Miami I think
that the Cuban community is still very
much a machista community but the Cuban
community is very similar to the rest of
America I have learned firsthand that
the reason people want to deny gays and
lesbians the right to marry has
everything to do with the fact that
there's still a good number I don't know
what that percentage is there's a good
number of people in America that think
that being gay is bad that being gay is
abnormal that being gay is sinful and
they don't want to treat us as equals so
that's why they don't want us to have
gay marriage they think that we're a
beret shion's and we don't deserve the
same rights
honestly the best arguments for honestly
the best way to overcome prejudice is
just to keep the conversation going and
realize that it will happen it's not a
question of if it's just a question of
when